okay massive breaking news regarding not
voter fraud but election fraud right
after the 2018 midterms we started
talking about what's going on in North
Carolina in particular in North
Carolina's ninth district now it's
really important to understand the
difference between voter fraud and
election fraud although really we're
talking about interference with the way
an election should be held but voter
fraud or an election fraud are two
different things in general when we talk
about voter fraud what we mean is
in-person voter fraud voter fraud at the
individual level someone goes to two
different polling places and votes at
both of them that is a form of voter
fraud barely exists extraordinarily rare
someone goes to a polling place knowing
that there are people who have died
still on the voter rolls claims to be
those dead people and votes for them
extraordinarily rare non-citizens
going to polling places and trying to
vote exceedingly rare I mean just it's
almost almost non-existent according to
every study that we've seen what is a
problem are different types of election
fraud this includes voter suppression
which includes reducing voting hours
voter intimidation changing the
requirements needed to actually go and
vote requiring IDs which while free
themselves
require other documents which are not
free or simple to get voting machine
tampering all sorts of different ways to
do election fraud and what we had in
North Carolina was an absolutely
disgusting example of Republican
election fraud and now a new election
has been ordered the story in North
Carolina's ninth district is of
Republican Mark Harris who narrowly
defeated the Democrat Dan McReady
supposedly by 905 votes
extremely narrow victory but there were
tons of irregularities we found out that
McRae Dallas jr. a known Republican
operative in the area organized a group
of people
volunteers paid shills who knows what
whatever they were to go and collect
absentee ballots in person and we don't
know the full scope of what was done so
far but our best assessment is that they
were doing two things number one the
Associates of Dallas would go to the
homes of in particularly known
Democratic areas and claim to be
election workers collecting absentee
ballots if the absentee ballots had
votes for the Democrat they could throw
them out or simply never deliver them so
that they would never be counted some
people gave them ballots which didn't
yet have which were not yet filled out
in those cases they filled them out for
the Republican signed off as the
witnesses themselves and then turned
them in as fraudulent Republican votes
we also learned that while this was all
being investigated Republicans withheld
damaging information about activities
that they participated in so this was so
bad that a new election was ordered late
last week Republicans are silent and
completely pathetic on this we heard
from the state party chairman Robin
Hayes who issued a statement after this
decision was made saying it was quote a
tremendously difficult situation for all
involved that's one way to call it but a
Republican cheated here what's difficult
is that your guy apparently didn't
really win Donald Trump Trump tweets
about everything Trump claims that voter
fraud is so important that he needed to
concoct this bogus voter election
integrity commission which of course
found no evidence of Hillary Clinton
receiving three to five million illegal
votes in 2016 it was disbanded in shame
having found nothing approximating what
Donald Trump claims exists and Trump has
been completely silent on Twitter about
what's going on in North Carolina in the
Oval Office late last week he was sort
of forced into giving some kind of
answer about it and he said well I
condemn all fraud including North
Carolina
so of course Republicans are silent why
because
try to win with election fraud while
claiming that it's actually voter fraud
that's the problem voter fraud is not a
problem something like 14 convictions
for in-person voter fraud have been
uncovered now there's a counterpoint
which is well not everyone is caught so
not everybody gets convicted even if you
accept every single allegation of voter
fraud as actual fraud you're talking
about 0.0002 percent of the votes that
are cast statistically meaningless but
we have Republicans on record saying
they can win with these tactics remember
Mike ters I from Pennsylvania talking
about it he straight-up admitted voter
ID could help Mitt Romney win we are
focused on making sure that we meet our
obligations that we've talked about for
years Pro Second Amendment the castle
doctrine Sun first pro-life legislation
abortion facility regulations in 22
years done voter ID which is going to
allow Governor Romney to win the state
of Pennsylvania done right
voter ID they see it as something that
can win them elections so the questions
that now come up in North Carolina's in
ninth district number one does the
Republican Mark Harris even run in the
special election it's not just a redo of
the last election my understanding is
that there is actually now a an actual
new election process and it's possible
that Mark Harris may not even run that's
interesting but more importantly for me
does anybody go to prison here does
anybody go to prison Pat because they
should and if Harris is connected to
this he should go to prison but I think
the most likely scenario is nobody ends
up doing time for really serious
election fraud I totally agree if
there's wrongdoing then people should go
to prison because this is very important
it's the most important thing to our
democratic institution free and fair
elections but hey I am glad that we're
going to have a redo election that
happens very rarely the
timon happened with the congressional
election was back in the 1970s so I
think we can take that as a win let's go
out there get out the vote and win the
seat for the Democrats yeah this is a
really important thing in general so
obviously in the ninth district in the
new election everybody's got to get out
and vote because imagine if after all
this either Mark Harris or another
Republican win again I mean disaster
okay that but we can't allow that to
happen but the message for progressives
is if every progressive votes this stuff
what matters way less because it's too
small a number to really make a
difference unless they become even more
blatant so in this particular case they
probably manipulated more than 905 votes
and 905 votes was the margin of supposed
victory for the Republican okay they
were blatant enough that they got caught
and now we believe we are going to get a
new election great voter turnout is 40
to 50 percent in a lot of these races
if progressives actually turned out in
droves and significantly increased voter
turnout they now need to steal 30% more
50% more twice as many votes in order to
flip the election how are they going to
do that short of actually just changing
numbers in the voting machines in
election machines without creating even
more noticeable activity and a trail of
criminality so yes we need to fix all of
these issues we need to focus on
election fraud and voter suppression
voter fraud is not actually the problem
but we solve 90% of these problems if
every single progressive actually gets
out there and votes and I hope that you
will in 2020 I know I will be voting
starting with a primary at every level
here for for the foreseeable future as I
have been doing for a really long time
make sure to follow the david pakman
show on Instagram where I often do Q&A
sessions with the audience david pakman
show on instagram follow me on instagram
at David Pakman as well
today's program sponsored in part by zip
recruiter hiring is
challenging but there is one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart it's a place where growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates and the place is zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman zip recruiter
will send your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards but they don't
stop there they use their powerful
matching technology where they will scan
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as the applications
come in a zip recruiter analyzes each
one spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match and zipper
cruder is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the first day and right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman that's zip
recruiter dot-com / PA que ma n one more
time
zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman it's the
smartest way to hire